- En douleur et au deuxième
trimestre de sa grossesse,
Pearl Gambler s'est présentée
en juin 2020 à l'hôpitalMisericr
des soins.
Deux ans plus tard  t toujours
bouleversée, cette femme crie
de la Première Nation Big Stone
raconte aujourd'hui comment
elle en est ressortie humiliée
et sans son bébé.
"Ma fille n'aurait pas dû avoir
à se battre pour sa vie",
raconte Pearl Gambler.
Les détails entourant son
accouchement sont troublants.
La femme dit s'être présentée à
l'hôpital sur la recommandation
de son médecin, mais dès son
arrivée, le personnel médical
lui est hostile, raconte-t-elle,
et ne prend pas au sérieux
sa souffrance.
Pearl Gambler allègue
qu'une obstétricienne a été
particulièrement brusque
lors d'un examan, la laissant
dans une grande douleur.
Elle et son conjoint auraient
ensuite été laissé àuxux-mêmes.
Elle soutient avoir accouché
sans aide, sous les yeux de
l'infirmier qui serait resté
figé pendant l'accouchement.
Son bébé serait mort quelques
minutes après avoir été
finalement pris en charge
par le personnel hospitalier.
"Pareil traitement ne serait
jamais arrivé à une femme
blanche comme moi",
dit son avocate.
Deux ans plus tard, Pearl
Gambler veut obtenir justice et
réparation. Elle réclamerrès
de 1,4 million à
l'administration de l'hôpital et
une gynécologue obstétricienne.
"De telles histoires sont
malheureusement trop fququentes
dans le système de santé",
dit le grand chef Arthur Noskey.
La Première Nation Athabasca
Chipewyan réclame également une
enquête publique sur le racisme
systémique ds s les hôpitaux
albertains. Covenant Health,
le gestionnaire de l'hôpital,
dit ne pas être en mesure de
commenter de cas médicaux
spécifiques. Mais l'hôpital
affirme toutefois prendre
très au sérieux toute plainte
de racisme et ajoute que
la discrimination n'a pas
sa place au sein de
son établissement.
Ici Mathieu Gohier,
Radio-Canada, Edmonto